[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días en france 24 este es
un magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
nuevos casos del virus del ébola
descubiertos en la república de guinea y
también en la república democrática del
congo han encendido las alarmas en el
continente ante posibles rebrotes de la
enfermedad los gobiernos toman medidas
al tiempo que combaten la pandemia de
coronavirus
el presidente sudafricano sin ramaphosa
anunció que su país recibirá 9 millones
de dosis de la vacuna de johnson y
johnson y otros 20 de facer esto después
de la decisión de suspender el uso de la
vacuna de astrazéneca por considerar que
no es lo suficientemente eficiente
contra la variante sudafricana del virus
egipto conmemora el décimo aniversario
de la caída del expresidente hosni
mubarak y de las históricas protestas
que llevaron al cambio de gobierno tras
una década los egipcios siguen clamando
por justicia para las más de mil
víctimas que dejaron las manifestaciones
de 2011
iniciamos entonces con la información a
quién aplica siete días porque el virus
del ébola ha vuelto a aparecer en guinea
conakry y en la república democrática
del congo en donde ya se detectaron
varios contagios las autoridades
trabajan de la mano de la organización
mundial de la salud en un intento por
evitar nuevos brotes de la enfermedad al
tiempo que continente lucha para
combatir la pandemia de kobe 19
este gesto ya era conocido en muchos
países de áfrica antes de la llegada del
cob y 19 en el centro y occidente del
continente el virus del ébola se mostró
especialmente letal desde su aparición
en 1976 hasta el fin de su último
rebrote a finales de 2020 el ministerio
de salud de guinea conakry reportó los
primeros casos de ébola desde su letal
epidemia entre los años 2013 y 2016 que
dejó más de 2.500 muertes estos nuevos
casos se suman a los tres reportados en
república democrática del congo que
comenzaron con la muerte de una mujer el
pasado 7 de enero al este del país la
nación había dado por terminados un
décimo rebrote del virus apenas un par
de meses antes en noviembre de 2020
tengo miedo porque el ébola llegó aquí y
mató a mucha gente así que tenemos a ver
que está de vuelta
dejemos que aquellos que están
encargados de la respuesta hagan todo lo
posible para acabar con el virus para
que no haya más víctimas por esta
enfermedad
las autoridades congoleñas con la ayuda
de la ms trabajan a contrarreloj para
que estos nuevos casos no se conviertan
en los primeros de una nueva epidemia en
el país le contacto al estrés hoy
repartimos registramos el trayecto del
paciente sabemos muy bien que tendremos
contactos incluso en la zona de salud de
catua y enzimas en donde fue enterrada
así que debemos rastrear el camino de la
paciente los guineanos celebraron con un
macroconcierto el final del rebrote de
bola en 2016
en este 2021 tendrán que esperar que el
virus no se sume a la pandemia de kobe
vamos ahora a sudáfrica porque el país
más afectado por la pandemia de kobe 19
en el continente africano se alista para
iniciar la vacunación masiva con los
medicamentos desarrollados por johnson y
johnson y fisher esto después de
suspender el uso de la vacuna de
astrazéneca que según estudios es menos
eficiente contra la variante sudafricana
del virus
durante su discurso anual del estado de
la nación el presidente sin el drama
fosa dijo que sudáfrica había asegurado
nueve millones de dosis de la vacuna de
johnson y johnson de las cuales 500.000
llegarán durante los próximos días al
país esto con el fin de comenzar a
proteger a los trabajadores de la salud
otros 20 millones de dosis de países
también están en camino según el
mandatario y el país austral superó
también el millón y medio de contagios y
los 47 mil muertos a causa del virus
hemos obtenido 9 millones de dosis de la
vacuna johnson y johnson
el primero de unos 80 mil dosis llegará
al país la próxima semana
más envíos llegarán durante las próximas
cuatro semanas por un total de medio
millón de vacunas a johnson y johnson
continuamos nuestro compromiso con todos
los fabricantes de vacunas para
asegurarnos cantidades suficientes de
vacunas que sean adecuadas para nuestras
condiciones en términos de la variante
que tenemos aquí
sin chances de ver la vida
y es que el organismo de control de
enfermedades de la unión y africana
aseguró que no se está alejando de la
vacuna contra el coi 19 de astrazéneca
después de que estudios mostraran que
muestra baja eficacia contra la variante
sudafricana por ende sostuvo que los
países que han registrado casos de esta
variante deben estar preparados para
utilizar otras vacunas posibles pero
donde no se encuentra esta variante
pueden utilizar justamente la de
astrazéneca
según el plan de vacunación de la unión
africana los países del continente deben
recibir 100 millones de dosis del
medicamento de astrazéneca este año sin
embargo a la luz de las advertencias de
los expertos en salud sobre la
ineficacia de esa vacuna contra la
variante sudafricana del cob y 19 el
centro de control de enfermedades de la
unión está pidiendo a los países donde
dicha variante es dominante que no
utilicen la vacuna por recomendación
para el uso de la vacuna de astrazéneca
es muy clara
de ver si tiene evidencia de que la
variante 501 b2 y es predominante en el
país entonces les recomiendo no
desplegar la por las razones que ya
conocen en la baja capacidad de
neutralización que tiene esta vacuna
ante la variante sudafricana
pero en los países que no han
identificado esta variante no hay
absolutamente ninguna razón para no
utilizarla y usted funcionarios del
centro de control de enfermedades de la
unión africana dijeron que realizarían
sus propias evaluaciones de la vacuna de
astrazéneca en varias naciones los
países africanos también se alistan para
obtener dosis de laboratorio
sino farm de johnson johnson y también
del fármaco ruso sputnik sudáfrica
suspendió el uso de las inyecciones de
astrazéneca a los trabajadores de la
salud y dijo que está abierto a vender o
intercambiar las dosis por las de otro
laboratorio otros seis países africanos
han informado de la presencia de la
variante botsuana como las ghana kenia
mozambique y zambia hasta ahora egipto
guinea marruecos y seis geles son los
únicos países africanos que ya iniciaron
la vacunación en sus ciudadanos si bien
los países de todo el continente tienen
considerables experiencias en campañas
de vacunación masiva muchos enfrentan
problemas logísticos y financieros
cuando se trata de vacunas contra el
kobe 19 aunque ya se han asegurado
millones de dosis la mayoría de los
programas de vacunación aún no se han
puesto en marcha una de las naciones
africanas que ya empezó con la
vacunación es guinea ecuatorial' la
nación hispanoparlante recibió un
cargamento de vacunas donadas por el
gobierno chino se trata de medicamentos
producidos por el laboratorio chino
sinovac que llegaron al aeropuerto
internacional de malabo la capital del
país uno de los primeros en recibir la
inyección fue el vicepresidente
obiang quien aseguró que la donación
profundiza las relaciones bilaterales
durante los últimos años china ha estado
trabajando en acercarse a los países de
áfrica subsahariana para estrechar
relaciones económicas y políticas
en los momentos difíciles
con un país está su pelo
dificultad como la que estamos sufriendo
hoy día en guinea ecuatorial
[Música]
si reconoces realmente los verdaderos
amigos que tenemos
por eso de verdad no tengo palabra para
agradecer gobierno chino y a su pueblo
por este gran gesto la nigeriana ngozi
okonjo iweala fue elegida como directora
general de la organización mundial de
comercio y se convierte en la primera
mujer al frente del organismo es además
la primera dirigente africana en dirigir
la organización liderada en los últimos
siete años puede brasileño roberto
acevedo la decisión fue tomada en
consenso por los 164 integrantes de la
mc en el consejo general la africana
asumirá oficialmente su cargo el próximo
primero de marzo para un mandato de
cuatro años
egipto conmemoró el décimo aniversario
de la caída del ex presidente hosni
mubarak producida tras 18 días de
protestas 10 años después el país vive
bajo la sombra del gobierno militar y la
ciudadanía clama justicia para las más
de mil víctimas que dejaron las
protestas
previamente hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en el cairo nuria tesón que
nos explicó la importancia de esta
conmemoración para el pueblo egipcio la
caída de mubarak efectivamente hace diez
años supuso un sueño de democracia de
libertad y de esperanza para muchos
egipcios la noticia corrió como la
pólvora por toda la ciudad había
cánticos había gritos había júbilo y
había sueños de un nuevo comienzo pero
diez años después la realidad es a la
que se enfrentan todos los días los
egipcios es exactamente la misma o peor
que la que había como barack un nuevo ex
militar el presidente abdel fatah así
está al mando del país gobernando con
mano de hierro manteniendo en la cárcel
más de 60 mil prisioneros políticos con
2000 de desaparecidos forzosos y con
cientos de jóvenes yéndose al exilio
muchos de los cuales participaron en
aquellos 18 días de protestas
con mubarak en los años que siguieron no
hubo justicia para las víctimas más de
1000 personas murieron en aquellos 18
días de protestas y a mubarak se le
juzgó por ello pero en 2017 fue absuelto
de esos cargos el año pasado falleció
casi con 90 años y a su funeral asistió
el presidente del gobierno se le
rindieron honores militares y para
muchos esa imagen es la que ejemplifica
perfectamente como no había intención de
cambio y como su muerte o su caída sobre
todo hace diez años tras aquellos 18
días de protestas no hizo caer el
régimen en noticias deportivas el equipo
egipcio al ahly venció al palmeiras en
penales con tres tantos contra dos en el
mundial de clubes y se quedó con el
tercer lugar del podio
palmeiras falló en tres de los cinco
tiros al arco mientras que el al ahli
logró tres anotaciones con las cuales se
ubicó en el tercer lugar del mundial de
clubes por segunda vez en su historia
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde senegal donde el artista santrich
presenta su nuevo sencillo en una
colaboración con el fallecido jazzista
camerunés manu dibango quien murió el
año pasado por coach 19 las imágenes se
robaron antes de la pandemia de
lanzamiento de esta canción se retrasó
hasta 2021 por la misma razón el
sencillo se titula a áfrica y se basa en
una canción de los años 70 desde dakar
hablamos con santrich sobre su nueva
producción
sentirme de to you congo brazzaville
ello y senegal hola soy santrich de
congo brazzaville y de senegal y tengo
la fortuna de presentarles mi nuevo
sencillo de áfrica que es una adaptación
de otra canción llamada le pusieron de
frank al book acá originario también de
congo brazzaville y que salió en los
años setentas standish z adaptación esta
adaptación retoma el tema ya posicionado
por frank al book acá en su época que
expresa la dureza de la vida de los
africanos y del congo pero sobre todo
reivindica la independencia real y que
50 años más tarde nos vemos obligados a
constatar que estamos todavía en el
mismo punto de esa dureza de la vida
allá estamos igualmente en un contexto
de kobe que exacerba estos problemas
desde yuretic de la vida el arma y
entendiendo lo bien esa independencia es
la de todo el continente africano que se
expresa en esas canciones
de piel en 272 de la frecuencia de
calibración pues justamente con áfrica
de sandro y finalizamos este capítulo de
aplica 7 días ustedes continúen con más
central 24 punto com nos vemos más
adelante
ya toca
[Música]
bajo la cama
hoy
más
[Música]